[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour j'aimerais j'aimerais commencer
en vous invitant à fermer les yeux et à
vous reporter à 300 mille ans au moment
où notre espèce apparaît sur terre c'est
un moment qui est très important parce
que ça va transformer l'histoire de la
vie de notre planète alors apparaître
quelque part en afrique un animal c'est
un animal qui est pas particulièrement
rapide
on n'a pas une force physique
extraordinaire on n'est pas capable de
voler on ne peut pas respirer sous l'eau
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on est si
différent des autres
alors il faut creuser à l'intérieur de
notre crâne est un organe notre cerveau
qui va nous permettre d'imaginer et de
créer tout le monde qui nous entoure
maintenant si vous regardez autour de
vous ici tout ce que vous avez autour de
vous à d'abord été imaginé par le
cerveau humain ensuite a été créé par le
génie humain puis réaliser ensuite alors
ça sert volet nous a permis de nous
développer nous a permis d'inventer les
symphonies de créer l'écriture de créer
la démocratie on a réussi aussi à créer
malheureusement la guerre des génocides
esclavage et l'idée chez les déchets
sont une invention humaine on est la
seule espèce au à avoir des déchets donc
l'être humain est arrivé et s'est
développée on s'est répandue partout sur
terre et au point où on est devenus
maintenant les 7 milliards et demi de
personnes et on a atteint une domination
complète
tellement qu'on est donné nous mène le
principal moteur de changement de
transformation de notre planète
c'est pas rien quand même et donc on est
entré dans une nouvelle ère géologique
une aire qu'on appelle l'anthropocène où
l'air géologiques récentes de l'être
humain pourquoi je vous parle d'une ère
géologique qu'est-ce que ça aux deux de
pertinent pour nous aujourd'hui je vais
vous demander à nouveau de revenir dans
le temps il ya onze mille sept cents ans
au moment où on est entré dans une ère
géologique les précédentes qui
s'appelait l'holocène qu'est ce qui se
passe il ya onze mille sept cent en mai
les glaciers se retire et le climat se
stabilise et pour notre espèce qui avait
été en fait parlants 280 mille ans notre
espèce avait erré s'était promené
partout dame sur la planète avait été
nomades par petite bande
on s'était répandu mais au moment où le
climat se stabilise qu'est ce qui arrive
en l'espace d'à peine quelques centaines
d'années
nous allons inventer l'agriculture nous
allons devenir sédentaire
nous allons créer les premières cités on
invente l'écriture et on parle de la
préhistoire à l'histoire c'est quand
même un changement très très important
une espèce qui pendant 281 de milan
étaient nomades parfaite petite bande
tout d'un coup commence à créer des
villes des civilisations les cultures
tout ça et c'est ce qui nous a permis
d'arriver à aujourd'hui d'avoir été sur
le plus grand sommet sur terre d'avoir
visité la lune d'abord on est capable de
faire voler des avions
on a maîtrisé la tome on est capable de
modifier génétiquement la vie on a
inventé
l'intelligence artificielle tout ça a
été fait à partir d'un moment où il ya
eu une niche de stabilité du climat de
la planète
une ère d'instabilité qui a créé cette
nouvelle niche le quai permis à notre
espèce de d'atteindre le niveau de
domination qu'on a sur la planète en ce
moment
cette période là de stabiliser de
stabilité pardon elle est terminée et
donc on était entré dans l'anthropocène
et je vous donnais juste quelques
chiffres histoire de vous donner un peu
le vertige
en ce moment les concentrations de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
ce augmente à un rythme inégalé en 66
millions d'années on a doublé les
quantités d'azoté de phosphore dans les
sols et ça c'est inédit 1 2
lire et demi d'années on est entré dans
la sixième extinction massive de
l'histoire de la planète la dernière et
s'est produite il ya 65 millions
d'années quand les dinosaures ont
disparu et on pense que sur une tendance
se maintienne 75% des espèces vont
disparaître et la banquise arctique qui
est présente en permanence depuis 13
millions d'années va bientôt disparu en
été
donc ce sont des transformations très
importante en fait nous sommes en train
de détruire les conditions les systèmes
qui maintiennent les conditions de vie
qui nous ont permis de nous rendre où on
est aujourd'hui on est en train de les
détruire et donc ça pose la question on
est on
nous sommes aujourd'hui un point
tournant de notre histoire nous sommes à
la croisée des chemins
et ce qui est en jeu pour nous c'est la
capacité future de produire de la
nourriture pour tout le monde c'est la
capacité d'habiter des régions de la
planète qui deviennent trop chaude ou
qui vont se désertifier qui seront plus
habitables ou d'autres régions qui vont
se retrouver sous l'eau en raison de la
hausse du niveau des mers
il ya des nouvelles maladies qui
puisqu'ils peuvent maintenant se
répandent à des endroits où elles
pouvaient pas il ya des nouvelles
maladies qui n'existe pas en ce moment
qui vont pouvoir se développer parce que
les conditions vont le permettre les
forêts primaires dans le monde sont
disparus on arrive au bout des
ressources en eau aussi donc vraiment si
on regarde le tableau de bord de notre
planète
on se rend compte qu'il ya des choses
qui vont pas qui tourne pas rond
et pendant ce temps là les gens qui sont
à la tête des grandes entreprises ou à
tête des gouvernements qui sont en haut
des taux des tours à bureaux
ils regardent leur écran d'ordinateur et
regarde dehors puis voit pas ces
transformations là un peu comme une
personne justement qui serait en train
de tomber d'un édifice d'une centaine
des tâches puis à chaque étage se dirait
jusqu'ici tout va bien jusqu'ici tout va
bien jusqu'ici tout va bien jusqu'ici
tout va bien jusqu'au choc final donc
c'est évident pour nous qu'on doit
absolument se réveiller avant d'en
arriver là et nous sommes pas la
première civilisation humaine à faire
face à la possibilité d'une autre
effondrement ou de disparition dans les
médias par exemple dans la péninsule du
yucatan au mexique
si vous êtes déjà allés vous allez voir
il ya des cités mayas qui sont
maintenant au milieu de forêts parce que
quand les cités étaient présentés à une
population assez grande éventuellement
on a eu de la déforestation et ça a
changé climat il ya eu le manque d'eau
éventuellement et donc les maillots ont
dû se redéployer se relocaliser ailleurs
la civilisation la culture maya existe
encore mais pas dans la même manière et
pau dans la même région
par contre si on va vers l'île de pâques
les la plus isolée dans l'océan
pacifique
en tout le monde a entendu parler des
statues de l'île de pâques donc un
témoignage qui a eu là une civilisation
qui étaient très avancées mais ils sont
disparus ils sont disparus ont laissé
derrière eux la question qu'on se pose
encore aujourd'hui pourquoi les pasqua
les habitants de l'île de pâques ont-ils
couper le dernier arbre sur leur île
comment ont-ils pu détruire des
conditions qui leur permettait de
survivre et maintenant si on revient à
nous aujourd'hui la planète terre notre
habitants une planète à l'échelle de
l'univers c'est une île de parts qui a
pas de possibilité d'aller se sauver
ailleurs d'aller très localisés les
seulement qu'une planète c'est pas de
planète b et donc la question cancale
sagan laisse trop fils c décrivait la
planète terre comme un grain de
poussière dans un rayon de soleil
littéralement un grain de poussière dans
l'univers ce petit grain de poussière
lost toute l'histoire des civilisations
ci dessus donc on fait face à cette
transformation là qu'on a provoqué nous
mêmes et donc on doit maintenant créer
un autre monde
on doit vraiment créé le monde dans
lequel on vit aujourd'hui on
créer nous mêmes et donc on est capable
d'imaginer un autre monde
on est capable d'imaginer une façon
différente de faire les choses pour
assurer justement le maintien de notre
civilisation dans l'avenir et c'est ici
et c'est la bonne nouvelle pour nous
vraiment de pouvoir imaginer ce monde
mais par contre si on veut imaginer ce
monde là on doit imaginer avec les
bonnes idées au départ einstein a dit on
ne peut pas régler un problème en
utilisant les modes de pensée qui les
ont créés
ça tombe sous le sens et matois nazis le
problème c'est parce que nous ignorons
le problème c'est ce que nous croyons
être vrai et qui est faux et donc je
vais vous proposer aujourd'hui trois
idées trois idées qu'on croit être vrai
depuis longtemps mais qui sont fausses
et 3d ce que si on les remplace vont
nous permettre de créer le monde qu'on a
besoin de créer la première de ces idées
là c'est que l'être humain est au sommet
de la nature ou à l'extérieur de la
nature que l'être humain domine la
nature en fait c'est une idée qui est
fausse mousse nous faisons partie de la
nature nous sommes interdépendants avec
toutes les autres espèces vivantes et
tous les systèmes naturels qui existe
sur terre je vous donne un exemple je
suis constitué à 70 % d'eau en masse
masse corporelle ces 70% de nos cellules
notre ca et sont composés en grande
partie d'eau et cette couleur peu moins
quand je me lève le matin puis je bois
de l'eau où elle vit à cent pour cent du
fleuve saint-laurent qui coule juste à
côté d'ici donc l'esprit de l'eau passe
à travers mon corps retourne dans les
rivières et continue comme ça
quelle est la frontière naturelle entre
une rivière le fleuve saint-laurent le
cycle de l'eau les nuages et moins il y
en a absolument pas c'est la même
de la même manière si on réfléchit à
l'air qu'on respire il ya quelque chose
de très particulier qui se passe entre
les arbres nous la molécule
d'hémoglobine qui transporte l'oxygène
dans mon sens est la molécule de
chlorophylle dans les arbres sont
exactement la même structure la même
molécule à l'exception que les molécules
d'hémoglobine et le coeur en faire la
molécule de chlorophylle est le
vainqueur en magnésium donc elle est
verte alors que l'hémoglobine et rouge
la première transforme l'oxygène en gaz
carbonique la seconde transforme le gaz
carbonique en oxygène et donc du coeur
de l'arbre au coeur de l'homme
il ya un échange comme ça qui se déroule
toujours l'être humain n'existerait pas
si elle est pas les plantes vertes et
les arbres qui font la photosynthèse sur
terre et là je pourrais continuer vous
donner des exemples comme ça pendant
longtemps
l'idée est tout simplement de comprendre
que nous sommes interdépendants avec la
nature et qu'on pense qu'on domine la
nature c'est cette même ce même mode de
pensée là qui fait en sorte que l'on
imagine aussi qu'on peut dominer les
autres personnes des hommes et les
femmes qui nous entoure les mêmes
rapports de domination qu'on offre à la
nature s'est lui-même les mêmes modes de
pensée qui ont mené l esclavage qui mène
à l'exploitation des gens et pour sortir
de cette idée là on peut s'inspirer de
la pensée autochtone dans plusieurs
nations autochtones
il ya cette idée que l'individu la
communauté et le territoire sont une
seule et même entité
- nous et la planète
les espèces et les systèmes naturels qui
nous entoure je pense maintenant la
deuxième idée fausse
la deuxième idée fausse et est que la
planète est un bassin de ressources
infinies à exploiter c'est normal qu'on
est con et crucell pendant longtemps
parce que il ya eu très longtemps l'être
humain n'avait pas exploré tous les
continents avaient pour exploiter toutes
les ressources mais maintenant on sait
on surexploite la plupart des ressources
de la planète et on a atteint beaucoup
beaucoup les limites des écosystèmes et
des limites des ressources nous donne
quelques exemples
quand on a commencé à chasser les
baleines bleues la baleine bleue est le
plus grand
animal à jamais avoir vécu sur terre
plus gros que les plus gros dinosaures
il y en avait trois cents mais dans
l'océan atlantique aujourd'hui en reste
moindre que 9000
quand on a commencé à chasser les bisons
dans l'ouest de l'amérique
il y avait 50 millions de bison sauvage
en quelques décennies en restait à peine
quelques dizaines et donc vous voyez la
plupart des pêcheries dans le monde
industriel sont en déclin ou en
effondrement avancé on a détruit je vous
disais tout à l'heure toutes les forêts
primaires ou presque la planète les
grands les forêts les vieilles forêts et
donc on voit bien qu'on peut arriver au
bout des ressources mais le corollaire
de l'idée comme quoi la planète est un
bassin et aux sources infinies
c'est que on peut exploiter en fait on
peut avoir une croissance infinie de
notre économie et une croissance infinie
de notre population
encore une fois on va prendre un peu de
recul on retourne en 1945 à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale l'économie
mondiale a été multipliée par dix neuf
depuis la fin de seconde guerre mondiale
et la banque mondiale nous prédit que
votre multipliée par trois d'ici 2050 si
30 ans la population de la planète est
passé de 2 milliards et demi de
personnes à 7 milliards et demi de
personnes aujourd'hui on va atteindre
près de 10 milliards en 2050 et au delà
de 11 milliards en 2100 alors je vous
demande seulement une pause ici essayez
d'imaginer est ce que c'est possible de
multiplier par 3 tout ce qu'on a sur la
planète en ce moment l'économie mondiale
encore une fois et est ce que c'est
possible d'aller vers 11 milliards de
personnes si on augmente notre
consommation individuelle toujours comme
on le fait en ce moment où est ce que
pour se rendre à des populations comme
ça on va devoir limiter notre population
de nos populations notre consommation
mais aussi notre population
donc on doit y réfléchit mais
aujourd'hui si on remet en question
l'idée de la croissance infinie
c'est un peu comme si on remettait en
question un dogme religieux
vous savez quand copernic au xvième
siècle dit la terre nous posent au
centre de l'univers la terre tourne
autour du soleil
qu'est ce qui s'est produit l'église a
caché ses écrits puis ensuite en galilée
repris ses travaux il y en a fait la
promotion
il a subi la dépression de l'église
pourquoi parce que les dogmes sont aussi
des outils de pouvoir pour les
institutions qui cherche à maintenir
leur existence telle qu'elle est donc il
faut être capable aujourd'hui de des
noms on nous devons être rationnel nous
devons asseoir nos décisions sur la
science et non sur le dogme et être
capable de dire de développer de
nouveaux modèles économiques qui vont
respecter les limites de la biosphère
je pense à la troisième et dernier à
l'idée maintenant c'est cette idée que
les lois humaines et les lois de la
nature sont au même niveau sont égales
alors que les lois de la nature sont des
lois immuables font des lois naturelles
alors que les lois humaines
elles ont été créées par nous et on a
tendance à l'oublier
on a l'impression des fois que les
institutions qu'on a créés sont
immuables mais pourtant la démocratie le
marché l'entreprise l'état toutes ces
institutions là toutes les règles qu'on
s'est donné son direct que nous avons
créé que nous avons inventé mais vous
savez quand on écoute les le bulletin de
nouvelles le soir on entend on entend
les cours de la bourse
un peu comme on entend la météo en la
météo c'est quelque chose qu'on subit
keane actuel alors on entend les cours
de la bourse la bourse a monté
aujourd'hui la bourse a descendu il ya
eu la stabilité il ya eu des orages la
bourse comme le fait chaud il fait froid
lui des tempêtes dans la météo mais
pourtant les marchés financiers ce sont
des institutions humaines qu'on s'est
donné l'économie ce sont des est une
institution m
et donc on peut transformer on peut
changer ces règles là pour s'assurer
qu'elles respectent les qu'elle respecte
encore une fois la capacité de la
planète et donc les règles humaines
doivent
ce subordonné aux règles naturel et pas
l'inversé
donc on a beaucoup de travail à faire
aussi là dessus je terminais maintenant
en revenant l'idée que nous sommes
capables de créer un nouveau monde
puisque nous avons créé tout ce qui nous
entoure et ce afin qu on dire bah non
c'est utopique c'est impossible parce
que c'est difficile d'y croire parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on a échappé
comme la main invisible du marché
c'est comme quelque chose qui nous
échappe ou on n'y en a plus de prise sur
nos institutions mais en réalité oui en
réalité on l'a déjà fait il ya eu un
jour où c'était impossible d'abolir
l'esclavagé
ça a été fait il ya eu un jour où ça a
été impossible d'affirmer que les hommes
et des femmes étaient égaux on le fait
aussi
toutes ces idées là est impossible un
jour qu'est-ce que ça demande pour
réussir à passer d'une idée impossible à
une idée possible tout simplement la
créativité de la volonté et la
créativité et la volonté sont des
ressources renouvelables à l'infini
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]